There's a very interesting side story going
on.
Given that we're talking about Corona virus
and Florida and from selection, there's a
side story that kind of pulls together Corona
Virus, Florida, Trump 2020 and more.
And the story is about the 2020 Republican
National Convention, which is now in jeopardy.
And more and more Republicans are saying,
I'm not going to Florida to a huge convention.
That doesn't seem safe at all.
And Donald Trump is now going to have to balance
the risk of holding a mass event in one of
the global hotspots, not just national hotspots.
Florida is a global coronavirus hotspot.
Trump would have to say, what are going to
be the optics of doing that?
What happens if turnout is terrible?
Because that's also the other side of this
right now.
So to catch you up, the RNC was supposed to
be in North Carolina this summer.
North Carolina's governor said you can't do
it at full capacity.
We just can't.
Given what's going on with Corona virus, Trump
was upset.
He moved it to Florida.
Instead, a lunatic Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis is like, sure, do whatever you want.
The latest news is that many Republicans are
saying they're not going to go.
Mitt Romney's not going.
That's not a huge surprise because he's been
one of the most vocal anti Trump Republicans
right now.
But other Republicans are bailing as well.
Senators Roy Blunt and Pat Roberts said no
go.
A Florida congressman, Francis Rooney, is
increasingly looking like he's not going to
be there.
Marco Rubio sounds to be on the fence.
He's a senator from Florida.
Imagine having an RNC in Florida to nominate
Trump and one of the two senators from that
state doesn't go.
Senator John Thune, Liz Cheney, there's a
lot of Republican elected officials who are
saying and it's not seeming like a good idea.
Republican Senator Chuck Grassley is a question
mark.
Now, consider the hypocrisy of this, given
that Republicans want schools reopened.
We had one hundred thousand active cases in
the country in March, April, and it was deemed
too dangerous to go to school.
So schools were closed.
We had a hundred thousand cases.
Close it down.
We now have one point eight million active
infections.
And Republicans are saying open up the schools,
but I'm not going to the convention.
That's way too dangerous.
And these examples are very wide spread.
You know, it's too dangerous for Paul Manafort
to be in prison because of Corona virus, but
all schools should reopen.
So this convention thing could end up being
a problem at this point for Donald Trump no
matter what.
Now we talk about self-inflicted damage.
He spent months saying the convention will
happen if it doesn't.
He looks weak.
So that's potentially a problem for Donald
Trump if he does the convention.
There's the problem of spreading corona virus
in a state that is racked with one of the
worst outbreaks of corona virus in the world.
If Florida were a country, it would have one
of the worst corona virus outbreaks in the
world.
And if Trump does it and the turnout is low,
he gets the bad optics of spreading corona
virus, plus the bad optics of people not showing
up.
So once again, self-inflicted damage.
Now, meanwhile, I don't even care about a
Democratic National Convention.
I mean, listen, I'm voting for Biden.
I know what the right move is in November.
I don't need a convention.
I don't need debates.
It's just such a clear choice.
Keep people safe and remove Donald Trump in
November.
Let's move on.
Get Biden inaugurated in January.
Hopefully, we'll have better functioning therapeutics,
more production of monoclonal antibodies,
convalescent plasma, maybe an early use vaccine.
Hopefully we'll start start to be available
up from a circus standpoint.
Of course, I would love to see the debates.
I would love to see the convention are live
streams would do so well streaming this stuff.
But I don't want anybody getting sick and
dying.
Even the sycophants that would show up to
a convention in Florida in the middle of a
pandemic would be exactly the people that
wouldn't want to wear masks and would be most
likely to spread disease.
So, you know, I, I would love to see conventions,
but they're only every four years.
I would love to see the debates.
But the truth is, we don't need them.
We all know what the right thing to do is
in November.
Now, as a reminder, the real reason they want
schools of.
One is not for education, it's not for the
mental health of the students.
It's they need the economy to look normal.
Many parents can't work if their kids aren't
in school.
That's really at the crux of it.
If you believe that your reelection hinges
on things like things seeming normal.
You want schools open because so much depends
on schools being open.
Putting cars back on the road.
Parents going to work.
Businesses opening.
A lot of it is connected to the daily routine
of parents getting their kids to school.
That is all that Trump cares about.
If you care about health, you've got to look
elsewhere.
You're not going to get anything health based
from
this administration.